Transcription: Solène Arcade
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Bonjour, je m’appelle Aïcha,
Je suis prof de technologie industrielle.
Je suis aussi étudiante, doctorante
à l’ENSAM de Rabat.
Avant de passer, Hasna est venue
pour me recommander
si je voulais participer au TEDx.
À l’intérieur de moi,
j’ai crié « Waouh ! »
Le TEDx, c’est une expérience
que je voulais tellement affronter,
passer en public,
me tenir droite devant vous.
Là, je suis en train
de trembler de trac.
(rire)
C’était vraiment un rêve
que je voulais tellement réaliser.
Pour surmonter ce rêve…
Pour atteindre ce rêve,
j’ai tellement hâte.
J’avais tellement envie
de temps pour rêver.
Une semaine auparavant,
avant que je sois là,
le trac, le manque de confiance en soi,
la peur a commencé
à s’installer à l’intérieur de moi.
Et c’est là que j’ai pu penser à chercher
comment sortir de cette situation,
me trouver des excuses.
Je suis malade. J’ai des réunions.
J’ai une conférence ailleurs.
Alors, vous vous rappelez une vidéo
d’une petite fille de cinq ans
qui voulait pas aller à l’école ?
Sa maman lui demande pourquoi.
Elle lui répond tout en pleurant :
« Je suis enceinte. »
(rires)
(applaudissements)
Alors, je me suis dit,
je me suis trouvée devant deux choix :
soit de surmonter cette situation,
soit de laisser tomber une amie,
la chose que je ne ferai jamais.
Et c’est à cet instant-là
que l’idée de mon speech
était tellement claire dans ma tête.
Aujourd’hui, je vais vous parler
de comment surmonter… des astuces,
comment surmonter une situation difficile,
un obstacle, à travers mon histoire,
ma petite histoire.
Alors je vous ramène avec moi
douze ans dans le passé.
J’ai été affectée à Kénitra, une ville
qui m’était apparue une ville inconnue,
entourée de personnes inconnues.
Je connaissais personne là-bas.
Je travaillais, j’étais emprisonnée
dans un boulot.
Bouffe et dormir, sommeil.
Je mangeais, je travaillais et je dormais.
Et pourtant, je travaillais
que mi-journée.
J’avais ni amis ni famille là-bas,
donc j’avais largement de temps
à ne rien faire.
Je crevais dans l’ennui, dans la solitude.
Et l’année passait, dans cette prison.
J’ai rencontré une ancienne amie
qui m’avait recommandé
de reprendre mes études.
Et c’est là que je me suis
réinscrite en licence.
J’ai rencontré des jeunes personnes
agréables,
qui m’ont redonné envie de revivre,
qui m’ont encouragée,
qui m’ont donné de l’énergie,
et surtout, qui m’ont rappelé
que j’étais encore jeune.
Après, j’ai été admise dans un master
et c’est là que j’ai croisé
la personne qui allait switcher ma vie.
C’était vraiment...
Je sais que chacun d’entre vous
passe par des moments difficiles,
par des obstacles,
par des moments douloureux.
Ça nous revient un premier moment
comme un choc.
Eh bien moi, mon choc a duré dix ans.
Euh, a duré un mois, pardon.
(rires)
A duré un mois.
Et durant ce mois, j’ai perdu dix kilos.
J’ai perdu aussi le sourire.
En marchant dans la rue,
je me disais, je me posais la question :
« Comment font
ces gens pour survivre ? »
Je savais même pas comment survivre.
Moi qui étais une personne pleine
d’énergie, toute souriante,
j’ai perdu ce don de Dieu.
Je me suis...
J’ai senti que j’ai vraiment touché
le fond et je voulais me ressaisir,
reprendre ma vie en main.
Et c’est là que j’ai trouvé que j’étais
emprisonnée de même... de mes...
de mes sentiments, de haine, de...
Mais j’essaye, de plus,
de partager mon vécu
pour que vous puissiez plus revivre
ce que j’ai vécu dans le passé.
Alors, je vous résume mon expérience
en trois astuces pertinentes.
La première : prenez, faites votre deuil,
criez, pleurez, évacuez
tout ce qu’il y avait sur vos cœurs ;
et c’est à cet instant-là, j’en suis sûre,
vous acceptez votre problème.
En acceptant votre problème
quand vous avez un problème,
vous commencez à réagir, à vous dire
vous décidez si vous voulez rester là
ou si vous voulez avancer.
Vous devez pardonner.
Vous n'avez pas le choix.
Si vous pardonnez pas,
vous restez bloqué dans votre coin.
Si vous voulez avancer, il faut pardonner
pour se libérer des sensations de rancune,
de haine et tout ce qui est négatif
qui assombrit notre âme
plus que nos cœurs.
La vie nous fait des coups, c’est vrai.
Certes.
Ces coups sont des leçons
que la vie nous apprend.
Si vous arrivez à pardonner
vous avez pris votre première leçon.
Après : arrêter de se plaindre,
de prier votre sort,
de pleurer.
Ressaisissez-vous !
Faitez-vous une bucket list.
Une bucket list, c’est une liste
dans laquelle on écrit tous nos objectifs,
tous nos rêves, même les plus fous.
Par exemple, je suis en train de réaliser
l’un de mes rêves dans ma bucket list.
Cet été, j’ai réalisé mon rêve
qui est de conduire une distance
supérieure à 2000 kilomètre
en voiture toute seule.
C’est vrai, ça va,
ça va vous apparaître un rêve stupide
banal peut-être,
mais pour moi,
c’est mon rêve et je suis fière
de le faire, de le réaliser.
Après ce mois sacré, je tente, inch’Allah,
de faire du parapente, du sky diving,
pour affronter la peur des hauteurs.
Après, après que tu fixes ton objectif,
passe à l’action.
Il suffit d’avancer.
Si tu n’avances pas,
on finit par te dépasser.
La vie n’attend personne.
Alors on avance.
La vie, c’est comme une bicyclette :
quand on avance, on est en équilibre.
Si on arrête d’avancer,
c’est là qu’on tombe.
Vous connaissez le charbon ?
C’est pas tellement cher,
ça coûte que quelques dirhams.
Mais sous la pression, la température
énorme, il se transforme en diamant.
L’un des plus chers,
l’un des plus durs au monde.
Alors essayez d'écrire.
Soyez la meilleure version de vous-même.
Avant de terminer,
je tiens à vous rappeler
que le passé ne revient pas
et rien ne dure pour toujours.
Alors vous avez chaque jour pour que vous
soyez la meilleure version de vous-même.
Merci.